Hey there, fella Heard you’re a gravedigger Said you buried a few famous people
buy your drink?
Cognac Top shelf
I’m ready to go, dad
All right, Tommy Hold your pants, son
I want to go with you, daddy Please
I'll bring you back something special
Maybe that gingham dress I picked out
No
Maybe?
They called themselves The Rufus Buck Gang
Some say that they were senseless killers
Pa please
Some say they were haunted by wild spirits
It’s all right son, we’re federal Marshalls
Their reign of terror began with the old Palmer family
Berjolene
One of the Palmers She’s gone
Heck wants to find her
before something worse happens
Let em send their best We’re gonna take them fools out too
And we’s gonna get this back in blood
I’m US Marshall, Heck Thomas
As God is my witness we will see justice done
I’ll trail them boys to wherever they’re holed up, then I’mma set an ambush for them
Go ahead and turn around for me
The great Heck Thomas
You’re gonna be remembered as a murdering coward
You’re gonna have to be remembered as the man who gets done in by Rufus Buck
Buck murdered a law man
What’s so special about this Rufus?
They think that he’s destined to be a great leader
I’mma make you all kings of this new world
Anything that y’all want is gonna be yours for the taking
This ends now
Well, how does it end?
Was there some big gun fight or something?
Whoa, whoa, whoa Easy
Get your money's worth